nous sommes avec le président du groupe
interne parlementaire d'amitié France
Maroc au micro d'Alexandre Poussard oui
Mohamed Didou bonjour bienvenue ici en
France au Sénat qu'est-ce que ça
représente aujourd'hui c'est demi-finale
de la Coupe du Monde Maroc France pour
les Marocains
d'abord que le Maroc arrive atteint la
demi-finale est un exploit aussi c'est
la première fois qu'un pays africain
arabo musulman atteint des demi-finales
donc je pense que c'est un point
important à noter le pense aujourd'hui
que aussi le la qualité de sport est un
critère de développement des pays et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui lorsque le sport va
ça veut dire que le pays en lui-même et
en train d'évoluer dans le bon sens donc
je pense qu'au 6 c'est un fruit d'un
travail dans le langaden je pense
aujourd'hui que le le Maroc et la France
vont se réunir vont jouer un match ça
doit pas sortir du cadre d'un match de
la Coupe du monde ça match avec dans le
cadre du respect mutuel des valeurs et
par la même occasion que en cas de d'une
réussite il faut savoir se comporter
dans un pays sans dans le dans le
respect total
ne pas abuser de de cette de cette
enthousiasme et rester
comme on a toujours connu la communauté
marocaine c'est toujours comporté
comporté dans des saisons avec la plus
grande crédibilité et sagesse
aujourd'hui ce match c'est important
parce que le monde arabo-musulman et le
monde africain et le suit donc c'est à
nous c'est c'est un exploit qu'on doit
essayer de d'aller jusqu'au but et aller
plus loin que possible rapidement pas
pour conclure ma méditation pour ce soir
vous savez
le cœur le cœur c'est le Maroc et la
raison en tranchera après mais le corps
c'est le Maroc notre carré marocain
merci beaucoup Mohamed Didou d'avoir
répondu aux questions de Public Sénat on
va tout de suite
[Musique]